in the West world season 3 finale caleb
takes to lorises brain because last
episode Dolores was fried by an EMP the
EMP now says reserved power on so
presumably all these outlier people are
still safely frozen in stasis which
could be important humanity now faces
apocalypse and possibly extinction so
they might need these hundreds of
preserved humans Dolores's voice
assistant guides caleb to a backup
dolores body at an Atty doshi
indistinguishable a plug de lorises mind
into a new body and caleb demands
answers so Dolores reveals that she met
Caleb years ago when Caleb joined the
military he was trained at a special
Delos Park where soldiers use hosts as
live targets we see Dolores hanayo and
Craddock all playing roles in this park
5 in the real world militaries do use
simulations and games as training so
it's believable that they'd use West
world's robots the West world website
always showed six parks and now we've
seen them all there's West world Shogun
world war world that made a evil world
of the raj and this military training
world in the park there are sensors in
Caleb's helmet because last season we
learned that the hats in West world have
brain scanners built in to record data
on people's minds that data is stored in
the forge where Dolores read books of
people's programming Dolores must have
read Caleb's book about his mind and
that helped her to predict and control
him this season like it probably wasn't
a coincidence that Dolores just happened
to fall into Caleb's arms she took him
on this whole journey of remembering his
past to manipulate him into fighting her
revolution to some extent Dolores was
controlling Caleb from the start but at
the same time Dolores chose Caleb for
his free will in Park 5 some soldiers
wanted to use the hosts for sex but
Caleb took a stand and stopped them so
Delores saw that Caleb could lead humans
to be better to end the cycle of
violence and abuse that Dolores knew
from Westworld
and this is why Dolores chose Caleb to
lead the revolution to free humanity of
course not being a rapist is a pretty
low standard to make Caleb the hope for
all humanity but the point is that Caleb
represents human free will
the ability to change and choose last
season said that humans can't change
have no free will can only follow our
code like our William is trapped in a
cycle of self-destruction caleb is the
opposite he was trained to be a killer
destined for suicide and yet he chooses
empathy and freedom and life Delores
says free will does exist it's just
[ __ ] hard the world breaks into chaos
earlier Dolores leaked everyone's inside
profiles revealing how they're
controlled by Rehoboam algorithms so in
Los Angeles protests and riots break out
it's a wild rebellion for freedom but
it's also controlled by Dolores she uses
the Rico app to move the riots to
certain places she pays performance
bonuses to protesters so ironically she
uses tools of control to fight against a
system of control just like Dolores
controls Caleb to give him freedom and
like how Ford controlled Dolores and
Maeve to help free them freedom and
control are opposites but control can
lead you to freedom like how having to
go to school can get you opportunities
later and freedom can lead you to
control like how free market healthcare
can put you in crippling debt and legal
drugs can lead to addiction we see
protesters using the maize symbol in
season one the maize represented the
hosts journeys to consciousness and
freedom now it represents humans
becoming conscious and
the show's creators have said that
Dolores deliberately planted this may
symbol to be a part of these protests
armed men on the street follow Caleb and
call him sir
the same thing happens in the movie
Fight Club when the protagonist finds
himself leading a revolution against the
system Fight Club ends with skyscrapers
exploding while a rock song plays and a
couple watch and this episode ends the
same way
so there's a lot of Fight Club stuff
here Dolores is attacked by Maeve Maeve
is helping serac get the encryption key
from Dolores
so that Maeve can go to the sublime with
her daughter but we later learn that
Dolores doesn't have the key Bernard
does and Dolores would probably be happy
for may have to reunite with her
daughter but instead of explaining this
to Maeve they fight
Dolores blocks may have sword with her
arm she says they built us to last
before they made us weak in season one
we learned that the hosts were
originally more mechanical with these
metal skeletons but now they're made of
synthetic flesh and bone more like
humans this backup body Dolores got is
one of the old mechanical models so it's
strong enough to stop Maeve sword so the
hosts were created to be like humans but
what makes the hosts strong is how
they're different to humans
Dolores says that all hosts are copies
of her because she was the first working
host and all other hosts are based on
her design so it's like she's the mother
or the common ancestor who the host
species evolved from in a way all hosts
have her DNA it's similar with Charlotte
Loras she started as a copy of Dolores
but she evolved and grew into her own
identity like a child does Arnold and
Ford were like Dolores as parents even
the Rehoboam a eyes are like the
children of Sirach and jean me Westworld
showrunners Jonathan Nolan and Lisa joy
had two kids together while they were
creating Westworld
so it's no surprise that the series
explores Parenthood so much Ford talked
about hosts as
new people to replace humanity just like
humanity's succeeded the Neanderthals
maybe technology and artificial life is
just the next step in our evolution a
continuation of the billions year
lineage that began with these first
dividing cells the Dolores defeats mave
but then Dolores is paralyzed by
Charlotte Loris charlotte appears via
hologram and Dolores ISA with the
contact lenses she's wearing apparently
Charlotte installed some back door
control in Dolores so that she can
disable her Charlotte wants revenge on
Dolores for how Dolores used Charlotte
in her plans Charlotte says that she no
longer cares about her human family Jake
and Nathan because that love just made
her wake which is similar to what
Dolores once said about loved ones
Charlotte has her own plans now and
doesn't want to Loras to get in the way
so Charlotte gets Dolores captured by a
serac so Charlotte defeats Dolores with
the same cold logic that Dolores once
used using and discarding her loved ones
taking revenge on her enemies
Charlotte is Dolores is brutal past
coming back to haunt her like a ghost oh
she's like Frankenstein's monster now
creation who turns on her creator just
black the hosts turned on the humans
Kaleb heads for the inside office so he
can plug in Solomon's strategy for
revolution he gets help from Ashe and
from giggles giggles catches a smoke
canister and charges through a police
line kiss giggles is played by a
real-world football player
Michonne Lynch kaleb's attacked by
security so he shoots them down with one
of these automatics self aiming guns
these security dudes should probably be
using an aimbot too because these guys
have been shooting and hitting nothing
all [ __ ] season Kaleb lets one guy go
free as an act of mercy again showing
that Kaleb can choose good over evil
of course Kaleb himself was once a hired
gun force Iraq so maybe Kaleb
sympathizers with these guys
Kaleb swipes a keycard to get inside in
you'd think that the place with the
computer that controls the world during
a riot against it would have better
security than this Dempsey's bank
account required biomarkers in blood and
even the etai dosing warehouse had two
passwords but caleb gets into super
Google's HQ with an anonymous piece of
plastic caleb has a we had fight with
sir axe assistant and then Caleb gets
captured Maeve realizes that serac is a
puppet of Rehoboam Rehoboam voice
whispers into sir axe ear and Ciroc says
and does whatever the computer tells him
he willingly gave up his freedom to help
the system save the world from chaos
which you could say is a noble
self-sacrifice
but Maeve says he's not even a man
anymore and this explains why last
episode Ciroc said the man he was no
longer exists he's given up his identity
to the system
he built a god and made himself its
slave in season 1 Arnold programmed the
hosts to hear their own programming as
an inner monologue to guide the hosts to
consciousness but serac has done the
opposite he was conscious and free but
he created a voice to take his freedom
away that's the danger of technology and
big data
humans are letting computers make our
choices for us we're giving up our
freedom to a machine God and return for
rate weights and neo points serac
captures Caleb and Dolores he wants the
encryption key from Dolores his brain so
that he can access the forge the human
data from Westworld
he wants to use this data to reprogram
these outliers to bring back his beloved
brother and bring order to the world so
serac plugs Dolores into rehoboam
looking like ghost in the shell' and as
he searches Dolores brain for the key he
deletes her memories one by one memory
is what gave Dolores consciousness in
the first place that's why Caleb gets
his memories back this season
memory gives us free will and identity
so it's incredibly cruel but
Lloris Toulouse what made her free Ciroc
says the Dolores is lying and
manipulating Caleb he reveals that
Solomon's strategy for revolution that
Dolores told Caleb to use would actually
lead to mass death and the end of human
civilization so it looks like Bernard
was right that Dolores is using Caleb to
wipe out humanity but it's not actually
that simple
Maeve connects with Dolores is brain and
enters her memory of this field with a
tree where Dolores used to talk with
Teddy in season one Dolores was
programmed to see the beauty in the
world and then she realized that the
beauty was a lie she was trapped in
Westworld blinded to its ugliness now
that she's escaped this Garden of Eden
she sees the evil of humanity but she
also remembers the moments of kindness
and goodness
so Dolores comes full circle and again
says she sees the beauty this time she's
not blind and innocent as she was before
she considers destroying humanity for
its evil but she decides the truly free
and conscious choice his forgiveness and
hope a hidden message online says passe
Dolores playing on a Catholic saying
about mercy Dolores makes a christ-like
self-sacrifice to forgive humanity for
their evil and to give them a chance to
choose the beauty so Dolores his plan is
for human civilization to collapse but
she doesn't want humans extinct she
wants humans to rebuild a better freer
world West world was destroyed so the
hosts could be free now the real world
is destroyed so that humans can be free
to lead this revolution Dolores chose
Caleb and Maeve so Maeve finally turns
against serac breaking from his control
and wounding him which she probably
should have done in the first place
Dolores is last memory has an access
code which gives Caleb control of her
home alarm so the future of humanity is
in Caleb's hands and he chooses to erase
Rehoboam
to destroy the system that controls the
world
apparently this causes the same result
as the Solomon strategy bernard says
this is the end of the world it's the
apocalypse that serac tried to prevent
so Caleb's choice may end civilization
and kill billions it'll certainly make
it harder for neural people like Caleb's
mom to get medical treatment but the
idea is that this chaos will ultimately
free humanity and give us a chance to
rebuild a better world
last season Dolores said that death is
the only way that humans can renew and
evolve Ford thought the same way making
hosts suffer and die over and over to
make them free Ford sacrificed himself
for the hosts freedom and now Dolores
sacrifices herself for the humans Caleb
and Maeve watched the old world burn in
season one Maeve was programmed to say
that in the new world you can be whoever
the [ __ ] you want back then that was a
lie Maeve was trapped and controlled but
like Dolores Maeve now repeats her old
catchphrase because now it's true in
this new world humans and hosts have a
real chance at freedom Caleb and Maeve
look like Adam and Eve a host and a
human as the hope for the new world on
the new RICO website it says all on him
now better not [ __ ] it up it seems like
the fate of humanity rests on Caleb like
John Connor in Terminator meanwhile
Maeve still hopes to reunite with her
daughter in the sublime meanwhile
Delores dies her memories all deleted
she sacrifices herself for Humanity like
robot Jesus oh maybe she's the
Antichrist because she does bring the
apocalypse
she killed a lot of people and she
manipulated Caleb even if she was giving
him freedom Dolores was controlling and
liberating she was brutal and
compassionate in season 1 Ford asked if
Dolores would become a hero or a villain
and the answer is Connor both there's
good and bad in her so we can choose to
see the beauty or the ugliness in
Dolores the showrunners say that this
version of Dolores is dead and gone but
there are other versions of Dolores out
there like Martin Loras and Musashi
Loras their brains could get back in an
Evan Rachel would bode and be about the
same or maybe Bernard could recreate
Dolores like Dolores recreated Bernard
so one way or another
Evan Rachel Wood could return to West
world but the big twist this season is
that Dolores didn't wanna kill humanity
and take over the world she wanted to
help humanity but a lot of a plan is
still either unclear or makes no sense
like what was the point of getting the
Soliman strategy if she didn't need it
to erase her her Balam did Dolores plan
to get captured so that her last memory
would give Kaleb access why didn't they
just destroy Rehoboam with an EMP or a
bomb on the several other times they
were here why didn't a Loras ever
explain her plan to Caleb when did
Dolores decide this plan and change her
mind about humanity what was her plan
with that host goo and the host making
data and the talk of a new species a lot
of Dolores plotline and motivations
aren't explained
so while Dolores and Caleb fight for
freedom and apocalypse bernard Stubbs
and William have a punch-up at a gas
station William said his new purpose is
to destroy all hosts so he shoots stubs
and gets [ __ ] slapped by Bernard and
then William runs away when the police
come
these dystopian cyberpunk looking riot
cops are led by de Lawrence
a copy of Dolores mind inside a Lawrence
body he is the fifth pearl he is
apparently been working for Dolores in
Berlin he's now infiltrated the SF
police and sets up these explosives to
blow up la de Lawrence also gives
Bernard the briefcase that Musashi Laura
sent last episode it contains the halo
device that Bernard will use to enter
the sublime so this is all part of
Dolores plan for the
not and first de Lawrence sends Bernard
to Lauren Lauren was the wife of Arnold
thirty years ago Arnold and Ford created
Westworld then Arnold committed suicide
and Bernard was created in Arnold's
image Bernard was implanted with
memories of Arnold's family of his son
Charlie and his wife Lauren
Bernard now knows that those aren't his
memories he never met Lauren or Charlie
but his feelings for them are still
cornerstones of his identity so Bernard
comes and meets his wife for the first
time and they talk about their grief for
the death of Charlie the memories hurt
but they're precious
because they're all they have left of
their son Charlie isn't really Bernards
son and Bernard isn't really Lauren's
husband she's just so old and senile
that she thinks Bernard is her long dead
husband so these relationships aren't
real but the emotions are so Bernard and
Lauren gets some closure showrunner Lisa
joy says Lauren gives Bernard the
freedom to move on from the past
it seems that Dolores sent Bernard here
to give him that closure before her
plans take him into the future Bernard
realizes that the encryption key
everyone wanted this season isn't in
Delores mind it was in his mind all
along that's what Dolores planted in
Bernards code that's why Bernard was the
one irreplaceable person into lorises
plan she gave the real world to the
humans but the hosts have the sublime
the digital paradise where some hosts
went last season she entrusts the key to
this world with Bernard Bernard puts the
wound at Stubbs on ice and leaves him to
rot Stubbs Abbes because Bernard
reprogrammed him earlier in a show about
how it's wrong to control and use people
it's pretty horrible how Bernard trait
stops Bernard plugs into the sublime and
he sees something we know a bunch of
hosts including Teddy and a cachito
have been living in this virtual world
for months now Bernard said that this is
a place where ho
can be free and they can make whatever
they want as though heaven is a giant
Minecraft world so what have they built
a host city a utopian future world
working gameboy color sir axe war world
simulation ran at a faster rate than the
real world
so maybe the sublime is the same and a
few months in the real world has been
years in the sublime the hosts could
have a whole history here but why did
Dolores send Bernard to the sublime does
she want Bernard to be a leader there
Bernard says he'll learn what comes
after the end of the world so maybe
he'll learn how the sublime builds a
free world so he can teach humans what
to build in the real world
maybe hosts could return to the real
world from the sublime and humans could
go to the sublime or maybe Dolores just
once been out to go to robot heaven
there are lots of possibilities but
Bernard stays in the sublime for a
really long time when he wakes up he's
covered in dust the room is ruined the
pot plant has disintegrated and stubs in
the bathtub must be reduced to chunky
soup Bernard was plugged into his oculus
rift for months at least maybe years or
decades this could be a post-apocalyptic
future after the collapse that Salomon
predicted all this ruin and dust looks a
lot like the post-credits scene from
last season when a version of William
was in dusty ruin sure annalisa Joyce
said this is in the far far future when
the world is quite destroyed maybe all
of season 4 will be set hundreds of
years after season 3 with Bernard and
Maeve and Charlotte in a
post-apocalyptic future where people
struggle to rebuild know or maybe
Bernard was only here for a month and
there was a dust storm and housekeeping
never came it's Sam big ewis but either
way season four will take place in
dramatically changed worlds both in the
real world and the sublime Williams sits
soaking in blood and whiskey
he wants to fly to Della's facilities
around the world so he can wipe out all
the hosts so he goes to a Delos office
in Dubai Dubai seems weirdly unaffected
by the end of the world but the
apocalypse should get here eventually
this apocalyptic promo shot seems to be
based on Dubai is real skyline the
william rolls in like a crazy old man
ranting at the receptionist about robots
William thinks he's the hero of this
story like sir Rowan in his book he
thinks that he's gonna save the world
but the truth is Williams a side
character he's so irrelevant that the
scene only happens after the credits
William represents the delusional
narcissistic arrogance of man William
finds a Charlotte Loras she's reprinted
her body but she keeps the burn on her
arm from when serac killed her family to
remind herself of how brutal humans are
Charlotte says Dolores was wrong to help
humanity and Charlotte wants the world
for the hosts it sounds like she wants
to take over the world and wipe out
humanity
so while Dolores chose to say the beauty
Charlotte sees the ugliness in humanity
Dolores said that she was torn between
two impulses helping humanity or
destroying them so when she split into
Dolores and Charlotte Loras it's like
Dolores became the heroic side and
Charlotte the destructive side the wired
side in season 1 Wyatt was an evil
destructive personality programmed into
Dolores Wyatt says that the land doesn't
belong to the old settlers it belongs to
a new God who walks on sand made of
human bones
Dolores played that genocide elincia
- but now Charlotte is like Wyatt she
wants to go full terminator reduce
humanity to a sandy wasteland and claim
this earth for the hosts and Charlotte
uses William in her plan she's created a
host version of William who seems to be
a perfect copy kind of like the James
Della's copy last season a human mind in
a host body that James kept
breaking down so maybe this William is
different somehow but whatever it is it
slashes human Williams throat apparently
killing him Williams story was always
about self-destruction he destroyed his
own family consumed himself with
delusion William was Williams worst
enemy this season he tried to kill his
past selves but in the end
William is destroyed by William
Charlotte seems kind of sad to watch him
die this Charlotte is a copy of Dolores
and Dolores and William had a long
relationship with moments of love and
years of abuse so this is revenge for
Charlotte but Williams kind of pathetic
in the end for all his pride and
brutality William dies in a Dubai
basement mourned by no one most people
think he was already dead this is the
sad fate of humanity if we give in to
our worst impulses if we fail to change
if we keep hurting those around us we
self-destruct with no one to mourn how
passing and William's torment isn't over
we know from last season's finale that a
version of William ends up trapped in an
endless loop so Williams life may be
over but his punishment is just
beginning
Charlotte has hundreds of hosts printers
maybe making an army to take over the
world
is she making hundreds of copies of
William the bad guy in the original
Westworld movie was a host man in black
attacking humans maybe we've come full
circle and the bad guy in season four
will once again be a host man in black
it said that Wyatt's men wear the flesh
of Wyatts enemies
so maybe Charlotte's army wears the
flesh of her enemy William or maybe
Charlotte's making lots of copies of
herself spreading like a virus like
Agent Smith in the matrix if you want
something done right do it yourself or
maybe Charlotte is making entirely new
hosts that was the point of the host
making data that she got from Delos so
this could be the first
generation of hosts created not by
humans to use in west world but created
by hosts to live in the real world but
what kinds of creatures will these hosts
be if they're created by charred loris
for the end of the world so there's a
lot of cool possibilities for season
four Caleb and Maeve and the outliers
could lead Humanity in a free world
while the apocalyptic charred Loras and
her army of IDI Harris's fight to wipe
them out and Clementine and Hannah yo
and Lawrence and dog loris might also be
around meanwhile Bernard oversees a
strange digital world in the sublime
paradise built by machines for machines
perhaps making whole new kinds of
consciousness in a separate stream of
time how it's best Westworld sparks the
imagination it gets you thinking about
the future and technology and identity
and meaning and whether its gate a spoon
a robot copy of yourself this is what
science fiction should be but Westworld
tries so hard to be smart that sometimes
its plots and characters are a mess
Bernard did almost nothing this season
about from giving vague exposition Maeve
spent another season having pointless
sword fights and being controlled by
others which even the actress Tandy
Newton said was frustrating since Maeve
was meant to have won her freedom
seasons ago serac was an interesting
character but despite his all-seeing
all-powerful supercomputer he and his
goons were completely incompetent in
stopping Dolores Ciroc was only defeated
in the end because he chose to plug his
enemy Dolores directly into the
supercomputer that controls the world
which is about as smart as sending your
credit card to a Nigerian prince and
once again Dolores's motivations were a
total mystery
until the end and it's really hard to
root for a character when you don't know
what they want and why so there are a
lot of problems with Westworld season 3
but it still explores import
ideas with ambition and depth and great
acting and production and music so in
the end we can choose to see the
ugliness in West world or to see the
beauty alt shift X is making more videos
about the Game of Thrones books and
covering series like His Dark Materials
and youn His Dark Materials is about
polar bears witches and killing God and
dune is about space politics philosophy
and sandworms
these are all awesome books and you can
get any of them on audiobook for free
right now by signing up for a trial with
audible members get an audiobook each
month and if you cancel you keep the
audiobooks sign up at audible.com slash
ASX thanks for watching this video and
this whole west world series and thank
you to the patrons including Liza and
Mike Hayden Kofi Carvel pilla Ava C
Rolf's Ricardo C Abdullah al-saad Paul
Crompton and Carlo Mendoza Cheers
you